really i want to start with you and
obviously it's a little bit generic but
this is your first
series if you will um what was it about
the material
that said i want to do this
uh great writing great characters great
big idea
because you know i'm i'm a i am
scot-free
with a team my team so we develop you
know quite a lot of material
and so clearly i part of my job is to
read it
and i read this uh and i was blown away
by f1 and f2 the grand idea
and the separation of the the division
of atheism and myth racism
and i i just thought it was i needed to
do it
and so i gradually got into it saying i
can
put time out to do at one and two try
and set the pace
i think it's appropriate because you
know i'm really an ex
i'm really a director who's an art
director and um
i knew what to do i knew how to make it
different and i i really want to
put put the pin in it i am curious aaron
when you
went to when you got this thing off the
ground at hbo max
how much were they asking um what's your
five-year plan what's your three-year
plan how much are they looking at
you know a series and lasting for many
seasons and how much is it sort of like
you know do how much do they care about
stuff like that
uh well when i originally pitched them i
did get i did kind of lay out
about a five season uh story arc
so they so i did try and i think just
the way the story is constructed and a
lot of the
kind of the the deeper mysteries that a
lot of the the
the story hinges on um required
me trying to go that far out into the
future to kind of you know
show to them you know this is where it's
all going to end up this is what this is
and so on and so forth
um so yeah a fairly pretty well mapped
out you know
a sketch but certainly i it's a map for
sure and know where it ends yes
ridley you've designed so many iconic
looks at sci-fi
um what is it like sort of i don't want
to say battling yourself
but you've done it a few times so the
the challenges of maybe doing something
different
well do you know what i mean like the
the designing the production look and
the visuals of the series
i rely on this good old eye word
intuition
i've got a strong intuition and which is
bolstered by
a confidence that i know i've got a good
eye i was born with a good eye
so the visual aspect of it for me for a
movie
is pretty easy uh but the good eye
when i'm reading good material it kind
of comes together and i start to see
images and that's how it functions and i
then
trust what i'm seeing go with it and
just
push it hard and push it through
and frequently it works gentlemen um
all i can say is congratulations first
six episodes are great
awesome thank you